although our economy is recovering
and although actually we grew faster
than almost any other country major
country in the world last year and
although we've got a lot of people in
work now
it's still a very difficult economic
situation out there that's why interest
rates are so much lower than they've
been in other times in our nation's
recent history so let's not think the
problems are over i first
for one second do i think the problems
in the british economy are fixed i think
the there's lots more work to do the job
isn't finished and while the interest
rates stay so low we should be helping
savers the big centerpiece thing in my
budget last week was a big tax cut for
savers taking 95 of people out of
savings tax precisely to help people who
are doing the right thing working hard
putting away something for a rainy day
we should be helping them be on their
side